you've always been a fascination to me
more than just a friend and let me let
me tell you why because when i first
came here
was uh
in the midst or the beginning of the
comedy stores uh strike i guess that's
right yeah yeah so for those that don't
know um the comedy store was owned by a
young lady at the time mitzi shore right
who got it in a divorce from her husband
sami shore and it used to be cyril's
nightclub right well if you have a look
at movies from the 50s they'll pull up
in front of cyros and that was sort of
the
new york style
club it was like a supper club
and you'd see like orchestras there and
i think that's even where lucy did her
uh rehearsals right i i saw that well i
know like tony bennett and all these
kind of people played it it was a legit
room
so she was like the copa it was like the
copa west yeah and then she got the room
in a divorce and in the divorce sammy
said sammy had built this club so that
him and his friends he was the opening
act for elvis presley right right and he
built it so that his friends could come
and do comedy right and then in the
divorce he said his friends should not
show up right right and then she ended
up recruiting like young people who just
wanted stage time for free right yeah
and and and and then um
the improv opened up out here
and
so what happened like people said that
they wanted because the place was packed
around the corner people decided that
they needed to get paid because she was
making so much money was it well what it
was was
you know it's one of those things where
they opened um let me shut off my phone
look how busy jay is
jay
who's calling it take it take it philip
oh phil i'm just shooting i'm filming a
podcast i'll call you call me back a few
minutes bye-bye go back a little bit it
was philip you were reading his phone i
was reading his watch
this is my daughter i know i know
i'm a detective i'll put that on philip
called here
you know it was interesting she had the
comedy store where we all worked
uh
mitzi had a habit of
sort of
well
i think she did it to be helpful but she
would it got to a point where she would
tell people how to do their act oh yeah
i know like jack grayman was a very
funny comedian and i remember she uh
said you're going to be jackie bananas
from now on do you remember this
and he'd wear a yellow jacket and she
wanted to perform that way and she like
jack raymond to be jackie banana yeah
jackie
yeah that's true yeah
but i mean she and she didn't like
people who were quote fully formed
like when seinfeld came in
he was a comedian he'd been working in
new york new york yeah and
he didn't really work though because
mitzi wanted
people she could mold and that type he
didn't get spots he didn't get a lot of
smoking no he didn't get a lot of spots
and
anyway so
there was the comedy store and then the
comedy store san diego then the comedy
store west and westwood and then the
main room opened up and it got to the
point where people were buying tickets
for
oh this is you know almost 50 years ago
25
right 50 or whatever it was a ticket
and she was making
a couple hundred grand a week
and the comics said
hey can we get cab fare or something and
mitzi was so insulted because she looked
at the club as
a college a place where you learned to
be a kid well so many people at that
time you know freddie prince got seen
there by the tonight show and ended up
getting his
sitcom right right and jimmy walker well
actually freddie
got seen
on the uh
on the tonight show he was on with
carson right but didn't he get the
tonight show from being seen because i
used to see johnny always say we saw
this young kid at the uh right at the
comedy store right i'm not sure it was
comedy or whether it was new york it
might have been yeah but that's again
those show business stories kind of
thing but the deal was
mitzi was very insulted by the fact that
people wanted cab fare at least to get
to the club you know right and
i don't think she did it for selfish
reasons i think she just
was hurt by this you know i mean this is
the standard thing is what usually
happens in any in life you know
you grow up to go into the father's
business and then you become
you want to be as good as the father or
you're better than the you know and then
the
infighting starts so i i don't i like
mitzi i didn't think mitzi was bad or
just the idea was like mitzi you know we
come across town we're coming in the
club is sold out you've got names of
people on the board
you can't throw 25 bucks a comic just to
do a set no nobody should get anything
done but so this turned into a huge
fight and the comics went on strike and
it got pretty ugly you know people
taking sides
and mitzi had a lot of comics that were
dependent on her they lived in her house
for free or the apartment that she had
for free
and they only worked the club and to
this day a lot of them still only work
the club well that was a thing that i
noticed about you when i came there was
there were teams you know there were the
improv the people that worked the improv
and there were people that worked at
comedy store and they didn't work both
you're probably the only person that i
know personally
that
was allowed to you'd pull up in your
motorcycle you do your set you'd get on
your bike go do the improv
there was no yeah i mean i went to work
and then i went home
i wasn't hanging out i wasn't but the
fact that she would book you and bud
would book you you didn't have
they were just thrilled to have you i
was lucky to be able to have a foot in
both camps and i tried not to play one
against the other
but
and of course once bud found out that
mitzi wasn't paying well then he decided
to pay everybody right you know it'd be
magnanimous you know all kinds of things
so all right so now you have one club
paying and one not so
why work the club that's not paying so
then it got ugly i mean i didn't go back
for
30 years
oh
you didn't you were out of the comedy
store well i left because
the comedy search just got crazy
with the cocaine and the drugs oh yeah
yeah and i remember i was in the back
one day and sam came in kennesan and
he had a gun and people doing coke on
the table and i said you know i'm a
comedian i i don't want to get when this
place gets busted
i don't want to get dragged downtown
you've already been in that kind of
world right when you work in like the uh
well yeah mob club
i just didn't want to be rounded up as i
mean to me it
it ruined the comedy store it became a
place for you know just sleazy women and
creepy guys and did you work both clubs
uh not really they didn't like me at the
at the improv mitzi kind of embraced me
uh well you worked the ice house too i
worked the ice house but the team seemed
to be the improv in the comedies yeah
yeah but anyway i i just stopped going
to the comedy store because
i didn't want to be there today i mean
sooner or later when people are openly
doing cocaine
cops are going to show up and i'm not a
cocaine guy i don't drink
i just want to be a comedian you don't
even eat vegetables i don't eat
vegetables that's correct it is true you
know 62 is my last vegetable that is
true he doesn't eat that you've been
eating like burgers and pizza i'm not a
vegetable and then you know is that true
is that an exaggeration no that's
actually that is true
really and so is that have you written a
diet book
well i should run it you should because
groups burgers hot dogs hamburgers pizza
pasta can i tell you you eat the same
foods as my five-year-old well there you
go you're exactly the same as my
five-year-old well there you go and he's
gonna grow up to be a strong healthy
child yeah but here's what i always
thought and i wanted and this is why i
wanted you on the podcast i like how we
got off on a tangent
tangents are my life but
[Music]
you